warum frauen bei einem date den raum
verlassen
durch den immer ganz kurzes nächsten
pudern bis gleich wenn sie drei minuten
weg ist besser wenn sie fünf minuten
wetzel das date ist so schlimm
der redet die ganze zeit über seine
mutter und über seine 20 katzen und und
wie dieses wie seine mutter und er die
katze gekauft haben
ja ja und dann steckt er sie irgendwie
man komische kostüme in einem
taucheranzug hat er sie rein getan hat
ist vorstellen die katze im tauchanzug
ey was muss das für mensch sein
ja genau du ruft mich an krankenwagen
krankenhaus ich muss zu dir kommen aber
so in zehn minuten ja genau
ja weil er muss noch das essen bezahlen
wenn sie zehn minuten wechseln
so was habe ich denn alles getrunken
ok geistig zusammen vanessa
was hilft nicht okay zusammenreißen
jetzt wirklich pokerface
weiter geht's wenn sie länger als zehn
minuten wechseln
und wenn sie gar nicht mehr wiederkommen
tja dann war der hund wohl schneller
ich kriege jetzt gerade einfach keine
and cartoon ich habe es schon zum
tausend mal versucht und ich hab mich
die ganze zeit also wir machen selbst
ganz kurz und schmerzlos
wenn es euch gefallen hat abonnieren
wenn nicht muss und vielleicht habe ich
die chance beim nächsten mal oder euren
geschmack getroffen jetzt schalte ich
das auch nicht weg wir lassen jetzt
einfach so und dann sage ich tschüss
eure x mal wanne so und bis zum nächsten
mal